so yeah I'm here to talk today about
rust as Jackie just said I was I've been
working on rust for about six years but
what she didn't mention which cuz I
didn't tell her that before that I have
been a pretty big fan of C++ for a long
time I just think Lea remember asking my
parents for this book must have been
middle school for for a Christmas
present and I poured through the whole
thing I couldn't find a picture of me
reading it though but I did find this
reading the Zen of graphics programming
with my dad at some point or another but
I thought was pretty cool but I'm here
today to talk about rust and so I know
not everybody here is familiar with rust
or even heard of rust at least based on
some of the conversations I had so far
so I thought I'd give a kind of really
quick intro to what rust is at a very
high level all right so the basic idea
is we want to take all these nice safety
guarantees that you can get if you write
a program in Java or C sharp or some
other language like that like that
you're not gonna have double fries and
segmentation faults in fact we want to
go further and say you also won't have
data races so your Kurla programs will
be more predictable and have a type
system that's more expressive that can
help you get correctness guarantees or
not guarantees but get correctness
beyond these basic guarantees we want to
do all of that without having to have a
runtime or a garbage collector or really
any undue performance overhead so I've
heard
be honest to sturb say the c++ tries to
leave no room for a language between it
and assembly rust kind of has a similar
ambition right there are people writing
kernels in rust and so forth so I think
overall basically our big goal is that
we want to have productive systems
programming and I mean productive in a
kind of global sense so how basically
how fast can you get your program up and
running how fast can you meet your
performance requirements but also how
fast can you or how well can you
maintain it over time right because that
can be a big productivity drag and today
is kind of a good day to do a talk on
rust because it's almost our 2 euro
birthday so to speak we had our one-year
1.0 release sorry two years ago on May
15th so yesterday and in that time rust
has been growing we've got a lot of
using it in production now I have a
partial list here of the most kind of
biggest names but you can see a more
complete list on our webpage
so of course Firefox has started to
integrate it when I say of course
because Mozilla sponsored rust but
actually it wasn't a given that it would
a succeed or B make it into Firefox we
had to kind of prove our way there as
well and Dropbox has been using it on
their servers and recently also on
client side NPM has integrated it gnome
hasn't actually put anything into
production but we've been working a lot
with the gnome team and we're kind of
excited to see where that might go there
are some gnome libraries starting to
experiment with rust so in honor of rust
being 2 years old though I thought I
would start with something two-year-olds
love which is I would tell you a story
and this is a true story although not
exactly as I presented here and it's a
story about using rust and so it starts
at a mmm at a working place in this
office center where Lady ADA comes every
day for her job as a programmer except
something seems dated okay this is
better so it starts at his cafe right
where every day Lady ADA comes and she
works on her program and what her
program is is a compiler so I told you
it was a true story from my life and
she's trying to make it go faster and
she notices that hey I have this there's
this one main thread that's doing most
of the work and every once in a while an
event occurs and when this event occurs
we have to update this data structure
and sometimes it takes more time and
sometimes it takes less time the key
thing is we don't need the result until
the very end
from this data structure so this is what
gives her an idea she says I could
probably make this go faster if I
introduced another thread right I could
have
now when the event occurs I'll just do
some lightweight processing to send it
off but the other thread update the data
structure which I don't need to use and
that will take some time and at the very
end I'll get the result back right and
if all goes to plan everything should be
faster right because the two threads
each have less work and we have more
than one core so she puts this to play
puts this plan in place builds the
system and it works and you know she
feels pretty good
the thing is six months passed this has
been working in production the compiler
is somewhat faster than it used to be
and then she's doing something else
entirely and to be honest she's
completely forgotten that there were
threads in the first place right so
she's just working on this some part of
the compiler that happens to be
modifying that same struct this by the
way is rust syntax but I figure you can
probably figure it out so this defines a
struct and this this event that happened
to be the thing that was getting
processed previously it just had a few
integers in it but now she has to add
something new which is a name which is
an intern string and this is where the
story gets a little bit scary so if
you've done kind of multi-core
programming or parallel programming you
know at least if you're like me your
heart starts to race when you think
about all the things that could be
happening now because what ADA doesn't
know about that in turn string she's
never actually had to look at that part
of the compiler in detail is that this
is how its implemented and this are see
of string that's kind of rough speak for
a reference kind of string kind of like
a shared pointer except our C is not
atomically reference counted so that
means that if two threads come along and
try to modify the read count in parallel
it could be wrong right and in
particular like I said we did just
introduce this thread that was gonna
send these events and hence send intern
strings across threads so there's a
pretty good chance that we're gonna be
modifying this ref count in parallel one
of them will probably get slightly off
this probably won't cause a problem
right away especially because these are
intern strings so there's always kind of
one big dictionary holding it at least
one ref but sooner or later it's gonna
cause a crash or maybe just gibberish
output or something right and it's gonna
be a big pain and waste a lot of time to
debug but actually none of that happened
because she was using rust so what
actually happened was that she got a
compilation error and she said what so
the type in turn string does not
implement send that's kind of rough
speak we'll get to a more detail later
for saying this is not a thread safe
type and she said why would it have to
be thread safe oh right I have a thread
I forgot about that and then she went in
and changed it and everything was fine I
mean this is kind of the experience for
us
aiming for it you can do things very
easily to start right so you notice it
took her only one day to put those
threads in that's also in well really
the stories about me so I'll switch to
the first person now it took me about
one day to put those threads in in the
first place
and that's only but that's only part of
the costs right the rest of the cost
comes later in the maintenance period
and we're Russ type system is really
great is when it can kind of deflect
these things that would have been very
painful and I only take five minutes of
your day now to fix it and get the rest
of the system back going right so there
is kind of these two parts the
productivity in the beginning in the
productivity in the end are the things I
want to kind of drill into more I mean I
think the productivity in the beginning
comes from a lot in large part from the
zero cost abstraction idea that rust has
kind of learned from C++ right so we've
got a lot of libraries that let you
write code that's very high level and
that compiles down to something very
efficient so this first example is a
function that tests if a slice or a
string rather string slice we call it is
all whitespace right and we can do that
by calling text cars which will give us
an iterator over characters which is
kind of like a C++ range we can call dot
all which invokes a closure on every
character and this is the closure syntax
in rust so we're saying for each
character C is C white space and that
compiles down of course to just a little
loop with a pointer kind of bumping
along this utf-8 string right and this
actually was a real life example from
some people who reporting Ruby code and
they had replaced like pages of C code
that was doing the same thing with this
two line loop and it performed the same
and they were very excited so the load
images this is another example doing
parallel processing using in this case
using a third-party library called rayon
that I'll come back to a few times it's
something I wrote but it's it's for
doing fork/join parallelism and you see
that it uses also iterators similar idea
except you just write power editor and
now you get a parallel iterator that's
executing in parallel but it's also
guaranteeing data race freedom at the
same time we'll see
and all of these libraries basically
rust is a language geared around writing
cool libraries that you know let you
write high-level things that perform
well but the best libraries in the world
aren't that much use if you can't easily
use them so we also have a nice package
manager
which lets you find the libraries and
add a few lines of code and then the
compiler will download them and build
them for you and so forth so that's all
part of the productivity story but
that's the first part that's just the
writing code to begin with then comes
the safety and the freedom that lets you
maintain it over time and that's more
what I'm gonna focus on in this Mis talk
because that's kind of the thing that
comes on top of C++ and I think if you
put these two together that's when you
really get to this goal of productive
systems programming so the structure of
this talk I'm gonna start with a fairly
technical part I'm gonna go through some
parts of the language how they work and
so forth and I'll focus on kind of a
safety the generic programming aspects a
little bit about parallelism don't worry
about the unsafe thing we'll talk about
that and then I'll get to some about
what feels like to use rust kind of
outside of the technical parts like what
was it like to get rust into Firefox and
what are some of the community processes
that rust uses to grow and develop so
let's start with the memory safety so
this was our goal and the interesting
thing about these top two bullet points
the zero cost abstractions and the
memory safety and data race VM is that
they're actually kind of in tension
there's a reason that a lot of languages
that have safety don't also have zero
cost abstraction and I'm gonna start by
looking at some C++ code to kind of show
you what I mean so here this is a few
lines right we already in these few
lines we see a few of some of the
features that let you build zero cost
abstractions effectively like we can
make full use of the stack in C++ we can
put the vector of strings has the fields
of the vector or inline onto the stack
and similarly the fields of the string
are in lined into the vector so all in
all when I want to get to my character
day
it only cost me two pointer dereferences
and that matters a lot if I'm going to
put this vector inside of a hashmap and
put an iterator on top of the hashmap
and put something else on top of that
all those layers start to add up if you
have to add a pointer at each point but
once you have the idea of a string being
embedded in a vector or what-have-you
you also need the ability to have a
reference right into the middle of other
data structures right to have a
reference that takes the pointer of a
field or of a particular array element
so this is something of course C++ has
and once you have that if you let then
layer on top of it deterministic
destruction meaning we're gonna free the
memory of this vector as soon as we exit
this this function right this is where
things start to get a little bit
complicated and so if I extend the
example now well I will just say however
this makes things complicated but it is
crucial to kind of maintaining your
memory use over time and keeping things
from ballooning out of control so if I
extend the example just a little bit we
can start to see some of the safety
problems right this is the same code I
have my my element or not the same
extended version of the same code I have
my element pointer reference pointing
into my vector but now I'm gonna call
vector dot pushback right and at this
point if the vector is at capacity we
could have a problem because we'll copy
over the old memory we'll put the new
value and then we're gonna free the old
memory and adjust our data pointer and
from the point of view of the vector
everything's fine right all the
references are up-to-date everything is
consistent but there's this dangling
pointer out here this dangling reference
of element that's pointing now into
freed memory and if I go on and use it I
can get into trouble right and even in
this simple example we see kind of the
outline of what happens if the issues
boil down to and there's really two key
ingredients that come together the first
is you have to have some sort of
aliasing so you have to have more than
one path to reach the same memory in
this case we had the elem reference and
we have the vectors data pointer and
then you have to have some mutation
because that's what makes things get
free that's what changes types like in a
union or something this is what kind of
invalidates references and the reason
these two things combine is if you only
have one
path to a given piece of memory it's
pretty easy to keep it up to date when
you make a change alright so if you for
example update the the vector kept it's
data reference up-to-date but it can't
keep track of all the elements all the
references that are out there in the
world so what Russ tries to do is to
layer on something we call the ownership
and borrowing system and basically the
key idea here is if aliasing a mutation
together are the problem then let's just
not have them happen at the same time
and we do this by having kind of three
main ways to access data which I'm going
to go through it's called one by one
right so the first one is ownership this
is the most common thing where you just
own some data and in that case we're
gonna see that you don't have any
aliasing because you own it you're the
only one who has access to it but you
are allowed to mutate it right ownership
we chose this word well we partly
because it's in use but also I think
well you have a pretty common-sense
feeling for what it means right so in
life if I'm owning and I have a book
it's my book it's on my bookshelf and I
can do a lot of things to it right I can
write in the margins I can read it one
of the things I can do with it also when
I'm done with it I can give it to
somebody else
and now it's their book and it's not
mine anymore and I have nothing more to
do with it alright and that's kind of
how data structures work in rust so
here's some rust code and it starts out
by creating a vector now this is our
first glance at rust syntax so I'm gonna
just point out a few things the
functions begin with FN were from a
company that's very familiar with
JavaScript where the function keyword is
function and it's very long so we tried
to make this one very short since you
type it a lot and then inside of a
function you can declare local variables
with let and this vet colon colon knew
that's invoking basically a static
method essentially new is not a keyword
it's just a method that by convention
creates an instance of the type it's
attached to and returns it to you so the
representation at runtime will be
exactly the same as C++ we have our
fields on the stack and I want to
highlight this mute keyword in rust
you'll see most things tend to not be
mutable unless you say so
in this case we're declaring that we are
allowed to write to this book and the
data that it owns and that's kind of a
helpful thing when you're reading code
you can see pretty quickly what's
changing what's not and so forth I'm
gonna indicate that with the little
pencil there so when I call book dot
push I get data living in the heap some
strings or what have you so far it's
pretty much the same as what we saw
before but where things start to be
interesting is here when I call publish
you see that it has an argument which is
Veck of string so if you have a function
that takes the back of string and rust
it's saying I need ownership of this
argument give me a vector all from my
very own and on the other side the
default then is to say well I have a
vector you want a vector I will give it
to you right it's not mine anymore so at
runtime what that means is we copy over
the fields that are on the stack and the
data sort of transfers with that
ownership transfers along and then we
kind of forget about this fields as if
we didn't have them right so now
published can execute it owns the book
it has the only access to this book it
can read it and when it's done
everything that it owns it can free
right it runs the destructor and now
when we come back this is where Russ
starts the diverge right so we gave away
our book but we're trying here to use it
again so what happens we get a
compilation error because the compiler
is tracking what did you own what if
you've given away at each point in the
program and it won't let you use the
things you've given away and we track
this on a pretty fine granularity so you
can give away one field of a struct for
example or some fields and then we
initialize but usually it's just a whole
variable at a time so this is somewhat
different than kind of copy constructors
right c++ has a very similar notion of
ownership but the defaults are are kind
of switched so if I have that same
example what transliterated into C++ it
starts out the same we have the memory
layouts the same and really when I call
publish in a way the signature here is
the same it's saying give me a vector
that I'm going to own however what
happens on the other side instead of
giving them the vector that we have we
would invoke the copy constructor and do
kind of deep clone of the data right and
now in from publishes point of view it's
all the same they own this book that you
can read it they'll free it when they're
done but when we come back we're in a
very different state we haven't given
away our book we still have it and we
could call it again and again and again
so you can do the same thing in rust of
course if you don't want to give away
the thing you have if you want to clone
it you can you can say that this is rust
code again by calling clone Oh like I
said we kind of switched the defaults
around so essentially in rust doing a
deep clone is explicit the default if
you have something that has ownership
and has a lot of memory associated with
it is to give on a ship away which is
kind of the more efficient thing so we
do have a special case for things like
integers floating points those are what
are called copy types which is kind of
like plain old data and basically as
soon as you touch them they were always
cloning them implicitly because there's
no real memory semantics associated with
them so okay so they're they're not
quite copy constructors moves are
somewhat similar to our value references
at this point we're getting past the C++
I learned in high school so if I make a
mistake you know feel free to correct me
but I think I have the basic gist right
so if we change this program to use
standard move right that's going to
create an r-value reference to the book
and the UH net effect is going to be
very similar at least in terms of
runtime to what happens in rust right
we're going to copy over the stack
fields but we're going to take ownership
of the memory and again published has
its own vector which it can execute
however again we're anis turn it sorry
it's the big danger of the animations
however we are forget it we're in a
different state when we get back
basically in the main difference is that
the compiler in in that variable book is
still of usable kind of variable lba1 in
a kind of unspecified state at this
point and in particular its destructor
will run when we exit the function and
so forth so in russa is not the case
when you give on a ship away it's as if
you never had it the destructor doesn't
run
it's basically all tracked a compilation
time and that that makes a big
difference not only because you find
errors faster but because when you're
building api's and things it lets you
use kind of say the zero size or phantom
values as kind of tokens that you can
give away and then you lose access to
them forever and you can't use them
again and you can enforce you can
basically layer that to build more
complex invariants in your api's so
that's ownership it's fairly
straightforward it is the most common
thing but actually in real life or at
least it's a very common thing but in
real life you know usually if I give my
book to someone I'm not saying take it
forever I'm saying here why don't you
read it and give it back to me when
you're done
right and that's usually what we want to
do with data structures too so that's
where borrowing comes in and there's two
kinds of borrows in rust the first one
the most common one is what we call a
shared reference it's written ampersand
T and like the name suggests it allows
sharing but we'll see that it does not
allow mutation because we said we want
to keep those two things separate so if
we go back to our example but I've
updated the type of publish instead of
taking a Veck of string it takes an
ampersand back of string meaning a
reference to a vector right and on the
other side instead of giving published
the book I'm using the ampersand
expression I'm sort of taking the
address of book but in Russ terms I'm
borrowing the book to make a reference
which I can then give so at runtime this
is just going to be a pointer that's
what an ampersand back of string is
represented as and we saw that it's
going to disallow mutation so I'm gonna
go into more detail on that after this
slide but for now I'll put the little
slash to show what I mean so now publish
can execute and it has a borrowed copy
of the book as a pointer to the book you
can use it and when it's finished no
memory gets freed right because it
doesn't own anything it's just borrowed
it and so we can then call it again and
again because the book has not been
invalidated by this so let's see now
this mutation thing I have this theory
that you can kind of everything you need
to know about rust you learned in
kindergarten which is kind of what I say
we don't break your friends toys just
kind of when you're sharing something if
you're borrowing someone else's thing at
least you really shouldn't be breaking
your writing into it and so
you should be nice to it and that's kind
of what happens we shared references
right so when we first create the book
here this is this combined snippet in
one function when we first create the
book it's in a mutable state and we own
it so we can do things like call book
push and that's fine
but when we enter into this block and
here I'm just using the block to scope
the variable R doesn't have anything
else any other purpose and we make this
reference we're putting the book into a
borrowed state the compilers mind right
and that means that during this period
where the reference is in use we can't
do mutations on books so we couldn't
call book push that wouldn't be allowed
and we similarly can't call through the
reference to the book we can't call r
dot push both of those would do the same
thing effectively if we allowed it so
you see here that we have two paths to
the same book you can go through the
original variable book or you can go
through R and you could also copy R and
make many references and none of them
allow mutation you also see that
mutation and rust is not a binary thing
it's not like this is immutable forever
or mutable forever it's really about in
this period it's mutable or in this
period it's not and that's particularly
here because when we exit this scope the
variable R is going out of scope now the
borrow ends and that means that we can
again call book dot push that's
perfectly legal at this point since
there's no references to it so I should
add one caveat I've been saying
immutable and mutable this whole time
and that's actually a little stricter
there are ways to mutate shared alias
memory but you have to go through
special API so essentially I have to use
unsafe code which I'll talk about later
so an example where you would want to do
that might be a mutex that's protecting
some data if you couldn't share it you
would just have the mutex in one thread
that's not that's kind of pointless so
you would want to be able to share it
amongst many threads and then have them
each acquire the lock to gain access
that's an example of a kind of special
API that enables mutation but the
default is if it's shared
you can't mutate it
so if we go back to our first example
now this is the rust version of a vector
that we're going to invalidate where we
have a reference to its 0 of element
that we're going to invalidate we can
see now that already this is the rust
compiler will rule this out right so if
we make an element pointer here we're
taking a reference to the zeroth element
of the vector that's going to freeze the
zeroth element but also the vector
itself because it's the whole container
especially because the russ compiler
doesn't reason about indices very
fine-grained in a very fine-grained way
and then we'll see we can't push on the
vector anymore because it's not allowed
while this element pointer is out there
okay so that's a shared reference and
the other kind of reference is a mutable
reference and as you might expect if
you've been following this table a
mutable reference allows mutation but
doesn't allow for sharing right let me
show you what I mean so here's my code
example I have a mutable reference to a
vector here it looks a lot like the
shared reference but it has a mute
keyword in it so signaling we're going
to do mutation now and on the other side
instead of writing ampersand book are
writing ampersand mute book
so again if you're reading through you
sort of see where the mutations are
happening at runtime this is exactly the
same as a shared reference it's just a
pointer but in the compilers mind it has
a different significance
instead of making that that pencil go to
an immutable state it goes to a kind of
locked state where we're not going to
allow access to the original variable at
all so now we can run our function it
can make changes through this reference
and they will affect the original
variable so we pushed onto the book and
we could call it again we haven't given
ownership away and all these things can
happen while we remain the owners right
so how does it look what does it mean to
block out all access well this is the
same kind of format here and we can walk
through and we see that initially the
book is mutable just like before but
when we make a mutable reference here
we're borrowing immutably now it's a
little bit different before you couldn't
do any mutations but either using either
path you could do reads now if we try to
use the original path
the book even just to read it just to
get its length we get an error but if we
try to use the reference we can do
anything we want we can read it we can
write to it we have full access all
right and all of this is temporary
just like before so when the borrow ends
we return to our original state or we
can mutate the book so the reason that
we have it like this now there are a lot
of reasons actually we found that this
scale better in various ways but one of
the reasons that's it's very easy to see
is that when when the rep the mutable
reference has soul complete access it
means you can do a lot of things like
for example you could send it to another
thread and you can be sure that the
original thread
there's no one's reading from it from
the current thread right I'm not reading
through it for through a book while
another thread writes to it from our
that would induce a data race and we'll
see that later on so there's one key
idea here that it's kind of been
implicit and I want to make more
explicit I've been talking about how
when you make a reference it freezes
this variable for a span of code like in
this case if I make a reference R to
book of 0 I'm gonna freeze the book
until the end of this block right
starting from the let until the end of
the block that concept this span of code
is what we call a lifetime and in
particular it's the lifetime of this
reference and we give them names
although not within a function usually
as we'll see you but across functions
sometimes you want to give names to them
so the full type here it's actually part
of the type of the reference if you go
into the full details so where I wrote
ampersand string that's kind of a
shorthand for saying a reference to
string and you figure out the lifetime
if we were gonna write it explicitly it
might look like that where we would say
ampersand tick L string so this tick L
the tick represents lifetime and that
means that a lifetime with named L
that's the lifetime of this reference
and it refers to this span of code so
we're saying this is how long the
reference is valid for how long it can
be used and the compiler won't allow you
to have the reference outside of that
lifetime so you don't have to worry
about this within functions it's all
implicit and in fact we don't even have
a syntax for naming it within a function
although I'd like to add one but
across functions is very useful so this
is a function that returns a reference
to the zeroth element of the vector that
you give it right and you see these
annotations here what these are
basically saying is they're they're
telling the caller who doesn't know what
the functions body is what this
reference is that as being returned
where does it come from it's basically
saying by tagging both of these
references with the same lifetime we're
saying I'm returning to you a reference
to a string that I got from this
argument V and that seems pretty obvious
here because there's only one reference
as input so there's really nowhere else
we could have gotten from so actually
rust doesn't require you to write it
explicitly in this case we have religion
rules that let you allied those things
but in sometimes if you have many
references can be important to clarify
where the value is coming from and where
it's not and then that allows us to kind
of track these borrows across functions
right so if we have this function first
and we have an example here I'm
borrowing book but all I'm doing with
the book you see instead of before I was
directly assigning it to a variable so
the compiler could easily see what was
happening here I'm passing it to a
function which is returning to us
something alright and the compiler can
use these annotations basically or you
to track what's happening and say ok
this reference some sub part of this
reference is going to be stored into R
and R is used in this block so I can
figure out that book is basically
borrowed until that reference R goes out
of scope and that means in particular
we're not going to allow you to say
modify book here even though there's no
direct reference to book anymore it got
passed away all right so that's kind of
the heart of rust essentially what I
just covered the ownership and borrowing
system or at least one of the the key
parts of rust but the other key part is
our approach to generic programming I
think this is another place where we
took a lot from C++ and we've tried to
add onto it
some other influences in particular some
of them from Haskell so I called this
section traits traits are
very like the cornerstone basically of
generic programming and rust and I think
you can there are someone analogous to a
concept
I'm sure the details are very different
unfortunately this is like clipping some
parts of the display but what that
should say is trait clone and it's so
we've actually seen this already earlier
I said if you want to clone a book you
could call book clone what that was
actually invoking was a generic method
called clone that's defined in this this
trait and so a trade is sort of like an
interface that you implement for a given
type and they can have associated types
they can have different kinds of members
the most common one is a function so
here I'm saying clone is an interface
with one method and the signature of
this method so you see these different
references to self the first part the
ampersand self with the lowercase that's
declaring the receiver so C and the the
this keyword is kind of implicit in C++
its explicit in rust in part because you
are there are different ways that you
different modes kind of for functions so
in this version I'm saying when you call
Veck clone I don't need to take
ownership of the vector I just need a
reference to the vector in order to
clone it I just have to be able to read
it so one nice byproduct of that is when
you read a interface declaration you
kind of see where the witch functions
will mutate and which ones were not kind
of like having a Const receiver and so
forth and so the other version of self
here this is this is referring to the
type so like a generic type parameter
saying the type which is implementing
this interface alright so when you call
clone whatever type you called it on
that's the type you get back so here we
have an implementation this is how you
would actually implement the interface
provide a version of it for some
specific type now here I'm defining it
for vectors that first keyword that's
cut off should be imple impl
like implement so we're implementing it
for vectors and we the basic model here
is very similar to C++ in the sense that
for every different kind of vector like
a Veck of you 32 of ech of string
whatever we will generate a custom copy
of this code to tailor to that type
right fully optimized for that type but
the type checking version how we handle
that type checking is very different we
do that
checking once on this generic
specification not on each individual
instantiation okay and that's where
these requirements come in with this
imple is saying is here's how you clone
a vector for any type T provided that T
itself is cloneable right and that's
because when you clone a vector you also
clone all of its contents so they have
to be cloneable
in the actual implementation we can
create a new vector here that was
something like we just saw only I'm
calling it V and then we iterate over it
I don't have time to go into exactly how
this works but basically LM here is
gonna be we're gonna create an iterator
and LM is going to be a reference to
each element in the vector in turn right
so ampersand T will be its type and on
each of those references I can call the
clone method and then I get back a value
of type T that I can push into the
vector and when I'm done I return the
completed vector so this is a very
simple way to clone a vector so most of
the time when you're doing generic
programming you're first of all using
traits and you're using methods but we
also have some traits that don't have
any members at all right there we call
them marker traits and these basically
express properties of the type they
don't have operations themselves but
they will enable other things some of
these are built into the language some
are not so here's two examples both of
which have come up briefly in this talk
so the send one the first one that's not
really built into the language but that
defines types that are thread safe and
types that are not and so you know
anything that kind of owns its its data
will be considered send it will have an
implementation for send and it's using
some various language features so that
it's basically automatic we detect we
have a conservative approximation for
things that are thread safe and we
automatically have such a trait beacon
has such a type be considered thread
safe so like strings integers and so on
those are all safe to send between
threads because when you send them you
also transfer the full ownership of
their memory but we saw earlier in our
very first story something like our sea
of string where you have implicitly a
kind of shared
well ref count that's being non
atomically manipulated that is not safe
and that does not implement sent right
and we have also an atomic version which
we call arc atomic reference count and
that one is sent and this is an
interesting example because I mentioned
that send is sort of automatic so string
in you thirty two don't need any extra
annotations similarly our C string would
be ruled out by this conservative check
but arc of string is not automatically
considered thread safe but it uses
unsafe code which we'll get to later two
kind of opt back in and say I know this
looks dangerous I'm manipulating this
shared state but I'm doing it in a
thread safe way so it trust me on that
and then we saw copy I mentioned that
for integers and things there's no
ownership tracking copy is a marker
trait that says any type that implements
copy can be mem copied from place to
place right so for floating points
integers and so on that works this one
is completely built into the language
because it's so core to the type
checking things that have destructors
like strings and RC strings and also
things that might have destructors in
the future like types that you define
are not automatically copy you have to
kind of opt in to say you're allowed to
treat this as copy yep no so the
question was our c string does not
support sin so what would happen if i
try to add it myself all right basically
and the answer is you can't do that
because there are rules called coherence
rules which basically define who is
allowed to implement which traits for
whom and so if you define a type you are
the only one that is allowed to
implement traits that you can that you
can see sort speak so sin is in the
standard library if your type and and
also string is in the standard library
so only the standard library can
implement send or not implement it first
string let's say and RC but if you
define your own type then yes you could
choose whether to implement send or not
for that type similarly if you define
your own trait you could implement it
for a string but you have to have
defined one of the two that way we
prevent there
being conflicting implementations for a
given type yes the question is if
there's two libraries one of which
defines the trait and one defines the
type they have to know about each other
to a certain extent right and the answer
is yeah at the moment they do we have
different features for that in the
package management system so you can
kind of have optional dependencies one
of them kind of optional dependency on
the other so that people can say hey I
want to if you happen to be using both
of these then please do provide this
info
but it's an interesting challenge it's
one we've been working on a while
because on the one hand it would be nice
to allow anyone to implement any trait
for anything on the other hand then you
can imagine like I have two different
ways to hash a particular type and I
have two different hash tables that are
doing two different hashing techniques
and if they go and get confused about
which one is in use where everything
goes crazy so we've been trying to find
a nice compromise between those two I
think we would like to enable it in some
way but we're not sure what the best way
is yet
yes Hospice Oh Haskell so Haskell
supports incoherent things if you opt in
I think but we don't allow you to opt in
that at the moment yes yes so the
question is could you to solve this
problem create basically a strong type
def like a struct that wraps it and has
only one field and implement the trait
for that and yes you can do that and
that's a common workaround sometimes
it's not what you want to low
inconvenient sometimes but actually one
part of the solution we've been thinking
about is just to make that easier to do
since it's often good enough okay so I
want to talk a little bit about
parallelism and I'm gonna lean here just
a little bit on the last two sections
right on ownership and borrowing and on
generic programming and
reason for that is that rust actually
has taken a big turn in its development
when it comes to parallelism we always
wanted to have a language that was had
strong support for parallelism but
initially the idea was okay we're gonna
build it into the language probably take
an Earl on like approach because that
seemed like the only thing we could
think there was going to work where each
thread has ownership of some memory and
they can send messages to one another
but once the borrowing and ownership
ownership and borrowing system evolved
and the trade system we realized we can
actually move all of this into libraries
and they can leverage these two systems
to to avoid databases and give all the
same guarantees that we thought that the
language had to provide so in fact rust
the language knows basically nothing or
let's just say very little about threads
he has a few intrinsics for doing atomic
add and stuff like that but other than
that it basically doesn't really know
much about threads and that all comes in
at the library level so it turns out
ownership and borrowing are or they were
we developed them for sequential
programming but they're really a good
tool for avoiding databases and if you
look at the definition of what a data
race is it kind of makes sense right so
a data race is this very common error
where basically two threads share access
to one piece of memory at least one of
them is writing to it maybe both and
they're not coordinating with one
another right they're not using any kind
of ordering to do that so this is
basically the first half of this talk
right it's all about can we avoid
sharing and mutation so if we're
avoiding sharing your mutation by
default we kind of don't have data races
at all and the only problems that you
have to be careful about is when you
introduce sharing mutation back like I
said maybe with a mutex or something and
that's when your API has to make sure
that ordering is enforced so here's a
cool example it's not cut off too badly
it's a parallel quicksort and it's using
rayon which is this library I was
talking about earlier for doing
fork/join parallelism it uses a few
rough features we haven't seen that so
let me walk you through it first off the
the input to this is a mutable reference
to a slice of integers and the slice is
kind of like an array it has you know a
number of I 32 s those are 32-bit
integers sequentially in memory and it
comes with a length also
so we can do bounds checking and we're
gonna do the usual quicksort thing so
we're gonna pick if it's only one it's
sorted already otherwise we pick a
random element and we partition to the
to the left and right so that we sort
kind of partially two elements and then
we're gonna call this split up mute
that's a library method that takes in a
slice and a midpoint so it takes and it
gives you back to your kind of two views
onto the same memory which are split at
that midpoint and it's a lesson greater
are now referring to kind of the left
and right halves of this input and it
might seem like we're violating the the
prime directive here by having aliasing
since now we have kind of a path through
vector and a path through less and
greater which can reach the same
elements but that doesn't happen because
of the features I was talking about
earlier it's kind of low but basically
where the function declares when it
returns its references we know where
they came from and so we know that less
and greater were derived from Veck
because they're ball annotated with the
same lifetime today and so we can figure
out that therefore while the less and
greater are in use the vector is
considered borrowed right
so when you call split at Moot you're
effectively trading in I had a reference
to the whole array now I get two
references one to each half of the array
and I lose access to my original yeah
okay so the question was do I also
specify that the ranges don't overlap
that's a good question and I will get
into it a little bit and then a little
bit next slide but in this case they
can't overlap sort of by definition
because we gave one midpoint and we said
zero to mid and mid over and those do
not overlap right we didn't give two
independent ranges but yes we might have
a bug in our implementation that's right
so well like I said that's coming up
actually that's perfect lead-in to a
later slide so so okay let's assume for
now that split up news correctly
implemented and we have two disjoint
views onto the original array then we
can call this method Ray on join so join
is a method to find a function I guess
defined in the Ray on crate which is the
library
and what it does is it takes to closures
as argument those are the parallel bars
all right and it starts conceptually at
least starts a thread with each of the
two threads one with each closure lets
them run and joins waits for them to
finish and then it returns to you but
one second Malka to under the head under
the hood it's actually using a
work-stealing runtime to do this more
efficiently right and the key point is
that these closures there's no the
compiler doesn't know that the closures
are going to run in parallel all it
knows is that whenever you have two
closures that exist at the same time
they can't both have access to the same
mutable state because that would violate
our prime directive right our prime
rules so basically here the compiler
will already check that the set of
variables at least mutable variables or
yeah instead of variables that each
closure mutates let's put it that way is
disjoint so here we have less than one
and greater in the other if I made a
mistake like say I use less in both or
Veck in one the compiler would flag it
as an error right and all that happens
kind of by the base system and rayon
doesn't have to specify anything about
that
and that sounds like the unusual bug but
actually I've made that mistake several
times every night copy and paste code
yep okay so the question was the
closures are they implicitly borrowing
by mutable reference that's a good
question
sorry yes effectively what we do is we
analyze the closure body and for each
variable we figure out essentially a
mode so it can be by value or by shared
reference or by mutable reference and
that's based on how you use it so if
they were only reading from less and
greater it would have been a shared
reference if they were there are other
cases it might take ownership like if
you take some vector and send it to
another thread inside the closure yes
another question so why don't you have
to specify ampersand mute when your call
cue stored in the closure the reason is
because if you have an ampersand mute
reference and you give it to a function
that needs an ampersand mewed reference
then it's a matching type
okay so the question is does the
inference take into account what I will
do with the closure the answer is yes it
does
sort of so the they're the closures
themselves they're callable right and
there's a trait for being callable and
so the way close a bit the base the
model code is very similar to the C++
model essentially they're like a
independent anonymous structure has
their various things that they touch as
its members and they may implement one
or more of these various callable traits
and there are three of them one for
let's see one for by ownership one for
shared reference and one for mutable
reference and so when you would declare
your function you're basically saying
like when I declare join I am saying I
need two closures and I have to specify
that I pick which of these traits based
on how I'm gonna use it so in this case
I would take the ownership version
because I'm gonna take these closures
and send them to different threads so
kind of they're only gonna get executed
once and so there's a there's like a to
two parts the the one who gets the
closure basically declares the
conditions under which they will call it
will they call it exactly once or at
most one sorry will they call it
sequentially always but many times or
will they call it in parallel with
itself and then on the other side based
on what you touch and how you use it we
kind of pick which is the max you can
support and they have to match or else
you'll have an error one more question
in the back so the question is could we
figure out automatically when you want
an ampersand mutant when you don't
basically for the variables
and the answer is that we could in some
cases it's if you get into the details
it can get quite tricky type inference
is that way but we actually I mean may
we're looking into doing some changes in
that direction but certainly not from
mute maybe for shared references but
it's unclear the the thing is it's
actually really useful when you're
reading rust code to have a visual
indicator not only of where mutations
will happen but also of ownership and
borrowing where where am I giving
ownership away lets you kind of predict
compilation errors better and so when we
had that in the past we actually took it
out we had some versions of it because
we found that it was kind of actively
confusing
you would think you would expect the
compilation error and not get one or
vice-versa
um so see what oh well you see it from
the signature of cue sort in this case
yeah yes so that's the reason that it's
called split add mute is that you're
declaring that you're taking you're
getting back to mutable references
there's also a split at that doesn't
have that characteristic and so the
thing I want to emphasize I kind of
brought it up earlier but the whole
reason that this works at all the reason
we can send mutable references to other
threads without kind of just because
they're part of the closure is because
of this rules that say when you have a
mutable reference there is no aliasing
alright there are no other threads
reading from it because even if another
that were just reading if another if the
new thread is writing that produces a
database okay more questions or are we
happy okay one more
do we have a plan do we plan on
specifying the type of the capture so I
I did I think the answer is I left out
one thing actually there is a single
flag you can use you can write in front
of the closure move and then the closure
and in that case you are declaring that
you take ownership of everything that
you touch and you do that specifically
when the closure is going to be returned
out of the function or in some way
escape the current stack frame because
then you need to force there to be no
connection even if it would have been
safe no we don't do it implicitly
because it actually affects the
semantics in some cases like if you have
a single variable and you increment it
are you incrementing the one on the
stack or your own copy which which one
are you changing so move kind of the
Clara's do you want your own copy of the
variables or do you want to use the copy
from the stack and I think using its
utilize your just a using move you can
actually emulate a full capture clause
because you can move a reference and
then you've effectively moved you've
kind of declared how you want it okay so
I mentioned that rust has a lot of
different paradigms I don't have time to
go into all of them
we just kind of saw how fork/join
programming works and how it builds on
borrowing I want it also builds on
traits I got distracted by all the
questions but I should say that the one
thing rayon joined does say it says I
take two closures it doesn't tell the
compiler they are running in parallel
but it does require that everything they
touch is send a ball right and we talked
about send earlier because it's gonna
send them to other threads so you better
not be using an RC or something that's
not thread safe in there so it leans on
borrowing and traits and we also have
other things right we have like message
passing this is built into the standard
library you can sort of imagine that
message passing is just ownership
transfer if I have some data I want
another thread to have it I just give
ownership of it and it's good the only
requirement is the data is sent that was
the thing that a doe ran into in the
very beginning right and we support
locking so if you have readwrite you
have read read locks and normal mutex is
if you have two threads maybe they've
API is set up so that basically if the
some data is protected by a lock the
lock owns that data and hence if you
want to get access you have to go
through the lock meaning you have to
acquire the lock so you can't forget to
acquire the lock and so forth and we've
doing actively now I would say a lot of
work on lock free data structures and
future style programming for
asynchronous i/o and so on ok so let's
talk about unsafe programming so a
couple there was a question earlier
about split at mute and the question was
how how do we know that it's right right
and so basically the RUS type system has
been designed to not be that smart it
has this relatively simple patterns of
ownership shared reference and meetable
reference which is enough most of the
time but doesn't cover everything you
want to do we've already seen some
exceptions to that like RC and so on and
for those things the way we do it is we
have the ability to opt out and go into
a superset of rust recall unsafe rust
and basically you write a write a block
of code using unsafe and then you can
kind of break the rules you can have
essentially C pointers that point
anywhere it can be shared they can be
mutable however you choose and on the
other side the idea basically is not
that you'll just take these unsaved
blocks and kind of sprinkle them
anywhere in your code that you happen to
be getting a type error I mean you can
do that some people do that but that
wouldn't be the best pattern practice
instead the idea is that you're supposed
to build an abstraction around it that
is safe all right and so split up mute
is an example of such an abstraction and
there is some responsibility there so
the question earlier was like how do we
know that they're disjoint the compiler
doesn't know it trusts us that they're
disjoint and we could design the API in
such a way that we have a bug and we
accidentally give off overlapping ranges
in this case like the logic is fairly
straightforward we're pretty confident
that they're not but you know it can be
subtle sometimes but we know that we're
not going to be able to kind of prove
everything the humans can do right so
that's not a goal of ours
it's just to get the most of your code
should not be using unsafe and the nice
part about this is when you have a
problem if you have a crash you have a
pretty good idea where to go looking
right
those those unsafe blocks and those
unsafe abstractions maybe you made a
mistake in one of those so I was trying
to get some good statistics to give an
idea of how often unsafe I know you
can't read that don't worry
how often unsafe code comes up I was
working with Diane haasvelt who's a
someone who works on servo which I
haven't talked about yet but servo is a
project I'll talk about in a bit and she
has a tool for measuring how much unsafe
code there is relative to other code it
turns out this is actually kind of a
hard thing to measure but we did our
best
within the russ compiler for example we
came up with this number
so the russ compiler is 350 thousand
lines of code more or less it's actually
excluding some kind of part of it but
and approximately 4% of that is around
in the routine is unsafe meaning there
are unsafe blocks kind of in its
vicinity and the a lot of that is
basically because we call LLVM so if you
think about it calling into c code is
kind of inherently unsafe right it can
do whatever it wants so there's not much
we can do about that so bindings tend to
be a really heavy source where you bind
to a C in C++ libraries tend to be a
really heavy source of unsafe code but
that gives you a feeling I mean I would
say my daily usage essentially I never
well okay I very rarely write on safe
code unless I'm working on rayon which
is that library for multi for
work-stealing which yes the core of it
is written in unsafe but even there
we've actually factored the library into
two parts so there's a core abstraction
which we don't change very often that
does the work stealing and then all the
like parallel iterator api's and all
that stuff those are all safe or just
layered on top which is really cool
because when we get polar quests from
people who are most of them are
targeting that stuff we don't have to
review those as closely right a few
basic tests is enough you don't have to
worry about beta races and other subtle
interactions and that's a really nice
benefit so I think I guess that applies
more generally but I would say
especially for open source where you
have a whole lot of contributions coming
in from a whole lot of sources and you
don't know how experience level of those
authors having a safe on say
distinction is very helpful so alright I
wanted to turn here and I want to talk
some about putting rust in production
and what that experience has been like
and so forth so we've we've recently
shipped rust in Firefox as I said it was
not a kind of completely no-brainer
decision for one thing Firefox is a very
big C++ code base and we are not going
to rewrite the whole thing at once right
so what we tried to do actually before I
go into this what we tried to do in
parallel with developing rust is we were
working on a project called servo
I mean servo is a essentially a
reimagining of if you did rewrite
everything from scratch if you said okay
instead of taking gecko which was built
in the 90s for unicore processors
without GPUs and we wanted to say how
would we render our webpage now with
today's computers what would it look
like
that was a big task and we had a lot of
early success and I'll talk about it
later but kind of all of that informed
the advanced features that we might want
to bring into Firefox eventually but
when it came time to really put rust in
we went looking for something smaller
something that could be basically the
smallest amount of Rusco that we could
actually put in so that we would then
have to do all the other work which is
the make files which is testing that we
support all the different platforms for
example Russ did not support WinXP at
that time and all these different things
that Firefox targets and so the choice
the first one turned out to be an mp4 D
mixer so this takes in an mp4 video
parses the header splits it out into
audio and video and this code was
written already in C++ it's actually a
kind of a simple operation but it's a
common source of security
vulnerabilities this sort of thing right
because it's all these indexing and
there are these mean people who will
like write mp4 files that are
specifically looking at your code and
the bugs in it trying to take over your
machine and so Russ seemed like well
that's a pretty good choice for that
actually when this shipped so this is
now shipping I should say I think it
shipped in well I guess here on the
slide you probably can't see it but it
says 2016 March
since then what you're looking at here
at this big blue circle is the telemetry
of Firefox so for users who opt in some
percentage of them we send data back on
kind of different measurements and and
and one of the measurements is we ran
this rust code in parallel with the C++
code so we didn't trust it fully yet and
we check that they do exactly the same
thing and this was how many times was
that successful so that's one hundred
percent so that was pretty cool and so
this is run now about 1.2 billion times
out in the world and so this was kind of
our first our first foray we have a
couple other similar things like this
planned I don't know if they'll make it
or not so one example is the URL parser
another thing which accidentally back
when I was working at that company
DataPower I remember that was the if
Hugo were mad at someone you were like
all right it's your job to work on the
URL parser now because it seems so
simple but it's really hard surprisingly
especially when you get data URLs and
all this other stuff and another place
where people can craft and try to attack
your machine so these these kind of
targeted areas are good places to
introduce rust in a sort of narrow way
all right and I should one of the things
that I wanted to mention here is that
Russ does make this pretty easy right so
we support the C ABI natively and our
structure layout can be made completely
compatible with C C structures so you
can very easily call it into rust from C
and into C from rust and vice versa back
and forth C++ is a little bit trickier
because it has such a rich set of
features right and we don't support all
them we're working on tools there are
the people who did this work of or who
have also done a lot of work as what
gets to in a second integrating with the
C++ code and Firefox and they've had to
support you know templates and the
classes and the different data layouts
and so on so we have some tools for
doing that but it's still a work in
progress so right so what are the next
steps beyond mp4 headers and URL parsers
so I mentioned this this servo project
which was kind of looking at how could
we do the how could we do that the the
rendering engine differently and there
were two main things that are now coming
from that project into Firefox itself
one of them is something called stylo
and this is kind of an interesting story
so stylo does CSS selection which I
don't know how much you know about CSS
but basically there's an HTML Dom it's
like a big tree and you walk down and
based on some predicates you assign a
different styles and so on and it's kind
of an embarrassingly parallel problem
and yet when we tried in the past to do
it and we failed to paralyze it and
there were a variety of reasons for that
some of them were like Microsoft's
compiler at the time wasn't compatible
with something else or there were a lot
of annoying issues of that kind but also
stamping out and gaining confidence in
the database in the database small
stamping out all the databases and
gaining confidence in that was very hard
because this was basically manipulating
all these Dom data structures that have
been designed from the beginning to be
single threaded and so people were
afraid that they might never get it to
work and that once they did maintaining
it would be a real headache and so it
never landed but now what we've done is
we've reimplemented it in rust so that
the main logic is happening in rust code
which is using FFI bindings over to the
those C++ data structures and that makes
the problem kind of easier because you
know that the rust code is already data
race-free and you have to just validate
that the layouts and so on are correct
so this has actually been successful
showing speed ups and that's pretty cool
but one of the things that we noticed
along the way of doing all this work for
multi-core is that actually that's
already kind of a little bit dated in
terms of you're a machine you probably
have four to eight cores but you also
have this big GPU sitting there that's
doing has a lot more parallelism
available to it so one of the other big
projects that we try to do is to move
rendering off of the cores and onto the
GPU as much as possible and following in
the model of game engines this is
actually a movie let me see if it works
so this is showing different engines
that was fifteen nine frames per second
five frames per second and then when we
get to servo we come to 60 frames per
second and the CPU is very low
so you can see that there's definitely
some benefit from doing that right and
that we hope to be moving that also onto
Firefox at some point so all right so
that's kind of I would say the other
than what these features are yeah yes
that was done in rust I mean I assume
that I haven't looked that closely but I
assume that the there's a certain amount
of whatever people write you programs in
OpenGL and so on to execute on the GPU
itself but I see not that I know of but
I'm actually not sure it's a good
question but a lot of the there's so
even though it sounds like it's all GPU
programming there's a lot of support
that goes into it a lot of all the code
around it is all in rust in short the
the next thing I wanted to talk about
was just kind of what rust development
process is like and the community of
rust itself so one of the things that
we've worked really hard on and probably
been one of the hardest things is to be
as opening as open and as welcoming as
we can to people from all backgrounds
and that means both technical and
otherwise but you know I think what
we've been a little bit surprised with
in rust is we expected this to be a tool
for C++ programmers and it is to a
certain extent right there are a lot of
C++ programmers using it are people who
or I should say systems programmers in
general write C C++ whatever but there
are also a lot of people who wanted to
write that sort of code but we're
concerned about the maintenance cost
about the learning curve and so on and
that they thought that if they actually
ship this product of their customers and
it crashes it could be a lost customer
and they didn't want to take that chance
so a lot of them have been we're working
and say Ruby on Rails or working in
JavaScript or something and nodejs and
they've been trying to experiment with
rust and we're pretty excited about that
kind of people from both directions and
that's helpful both
people using rust but also for getting a
diversity of ideas about how to improve
rust so I think a lot of those languages
come with a very different expectation
in terms of how much the how the Lang
what the interface to the language and
the user will be right so if you
followed rust at all you at least prior
to the 1.0 release you probably noticed
at least one thing about it which was
that we changed it a lot
there was a definitely a period so I've
been working on rust six years almost
and we've been two years of stability
and I can tell you that before that if I
had some code that was six weeks old I
would just erase it like it was no it
was not gonna compile it's gonna be a
lot of work I might as well just rewrite
it
that's exaggerating a little but it is
true that it definitely wouldn't have
built and we had to do is because we
were doing a lot of experimentation
finding how the system should work and
that took us a while and so when we
declared the 1.0 release we definitely
wanted an end to that right we were
tired of it
and so our goal is basically to say it's
not that will never change rust but that
it's never you will never be afraid to
upgrade it because you won't have a hard
time getting your code to compile and so
on and so we can maintain compatibility
and and we'll do that in perpetuity
right but the danger is okay if we're
gonna maintain compatibility can we keep
innovating can we keep improving rust
and how can we do that and so we've been
working on a system to let us
it sort of lets us do that in a very
flexible way and we call this our kind
of feature pipeline so if you want to
add something to rust it starts out in
the RFC phase right and this is this is
true whether you are in the rust core
team or whether you are somebody who's
never worked in rust before if you have
some cool idea you want to put into rust
you write up a description how it should
work and you put it up on our RFC repo
and you will get a lot of feedback
actually probably a better starting
point before you post the description is
to put it in the forum's and iterate a
little there but regardless you
every RFC that goes in kind of improves
on the way before it comes out is what
we found and even when we think we have
an idea that's guaranteed perfect we've
got it all set up and this is where it's
really great that we have such a sort of
diverse community and also where we work
really hard to keep the conversations
pleasant because for a lot of people
including myself
if you post up some ideas that you had
and you get a whole lot of blistering
negative feedback it's really
discouraging right and it can prevent
you not only is it discouraging and I
mean you may walk away but we may never
find the better solution so we're always
looking for ways to kind of get the best
of both worlds without sacrificing if
that's possible to overcome the
trade-off so once we get through the RFC
process we move to this nightly
release so basically the Russ compiler
is kind of taking a model from browsers
here until we release more or less every
night sometimes the builds don't succeed
for one way or not reason or another the
current master branch and you can use
that and people do and then you
basically have the bleeding edge so
that's where new features will get
implemented there first and if you use
them to use these unstable features that
are still in iteration you have to opt
into it in your code you kind of declare
okay I'm using an unstable feature here
I know that my code may not build
tomorrow I accept that and that's how
you can then give feedback and influence
the direction so just because an RFC is
accepted doesn't mean that the final
state of the feature is known right we
kind of work on it over time and then
every six weeks we will cut out a
release and we'll say okay this this
contains only those set of features that
were happy with all the other ones that
we're still iterating on those aren't
usable from this stable release so if
you don't want to have the risk that
your code breaks you can just stick with
stable and you're all set and every once
in a while when we see we feel like a
feature is done then we will declare
that it's stable and it'll go on to the
stable release so that that this
pipeline has served us pretty well for a
letting things simultaneously be
actively developed while keeping a core
set stable we also do a lot of testing
so I mentioned like the crates that i/o
repository so for example we run the
compiler against all of it on a regular
basis checking to make sure everything
still works the same as it used to and
so on
so that brings me to roughly the end of
my talk I want to leave you with a few
things first off there is a bunch of
resources if you're interested in rust
we've recently completed a new book
which I think is very exciting it has a
really good direction for for learning
rust and covering all of those various
features let me have a users mailing
list we have an IRC channel I think
there's probably slack and other things
although not official as well and as I
said we work really hard to make sure
that these are friendly places to come
and ask questions and the last thing
I'll point you at is I have this
screencast collection of screencasts
called into rust comm which kind of take
a similar - style to what I did here
teaching you the different aspects of
rust and so forth so one thing I should
mention because I always forget I have a
lot of stickers if you like stickers
please come and find me also if you have
any questions about rust and so on